e da un po che va quest'usanza di
tingersi i capelli per fare il virus
alla cazzo di cane perché non si sa
perché i video dove ti tingi capelli fa
fanno le views
non ho mai capito perché segue però
funziona funziona
pensa se divento pelato conte vispa
vabbè lasciamo di fatto ragazzi è che io
non ho scelto di fare questa cosa la
differenza tra tutti quelli che fanno si
fanno i capelli colorati per fare le
views e perché lo sappiamo che fate le
views così maldestri birichini la
differenza è che io non ho scelto di
fare questa cosa va a fan culo me
l'hanno fatta perché ho perso un
challenge su social face e quindi mi
hanno fatto questa penitenza vi faccio
vedere com'è andata la situazione in sé
purtroppo
buona visione
basta ma tutto è da qualcuno non molto
contento allora saga particolare da fare
è tanta perché lo schifo che la barba ok
vediamo dai dai dai forza grado dai dai
che vuoi che sia
non sapevamo precisamente che cosa fare
quindi ci siamo affidati a lui per fare
un restyling su lorenzo come noto dire
quella roba che ci interessa con la
parte ghana per renderlo un po più
felice punterei su un bel colore
sgargiante preso qualcosa nella società
un'usanza quale vanta ed automatico mi
raccomando non muoverti da questa
votazione
ho chiesto un bavaglio è stato mai
felice e lo sa
ma io posso guardare quello che stai
facendo presenta li dico price
no no no no ma si sa se non bastasse
[Musica]
sei dei ragazzi non mi dovete portare
cloud state lontani dalla città massimo
risultato guardo a trovarlo non si è
fatto vedere cosa fa la panda e poi
senza fatica per portarlo lì che cosa è
successo
oh mio dio
benissimo
era una penitenza era una penitenza è
piaciuta onore verde o cannibali mia
fatti capanna all che questa era felice
ho però tutto sommato non è così male
io quando mi sono girato attraverso il
peggio sembra tipo joker alla lontana
tanto lontana troppo lontano quindi
ragazzi questa è stata la mia esperienza
nel tingermi i capelli ovviamente appena
sono arrivato a casa o ficcato la testa
dentro la candeggina joker non alla
lontana joker nuovo vedo mango il
cannocchiale volo mettervi un altro
challenge di social face che mi ha
divertito un sacco che ancora non avevo
messo che era quella dei cavalieri
praticamente bisognava colpirsi con una
spada sporca di vernice e chi colpiva
l'altro per primo vince va abbiamo fatto
quattro land io contro sasha e niente vi
lascio al video perché secondo me merita
più dei capelli molto di più però fanno
più views i capelli non so perché i b b
va youtube madonne e messe di
il reame di social fretta
invece per stabilire chi sarà lo
cavaliere più bello dos dell'etere tutto
signori ragazzi ragazzi siamo qui oggi
per un matrimonio non siamo qua per
sfidarci io e sasha perché lui ha voluto
fare questa sfida bello questo gioco si
chi si colpisce prima vince con vernici
cosa devi fare quattro sfide che arriva
a chi fa più punti vince dai sfida tanto
di fatto by sa che non ho mai visto
neanche vedere sto andando ma predica
artistico ha davanti il colore guardava
vicino controlliamo vediamo c'è un punto
ciascuno rosa che ancora più fiera
bye bye bye bye carico del nome due
[Musica]
diversi premi tutti quello già c'era
questo non c'era guarda nuovo questo è
come se nuovo questa è una maglietta
l'ha condannata così mi sa che è 2 1 per
noi ha un esposto del suo driver lo
scemo via la spada ne va via l'elmo ma
niente che cosa commentiamo il casco si
muovono che sai come l'agnello scudo è
però va bene ma se lo volesse perché
praticamente in cosa consiste per
prefetto è subito diretto
fate male 1
[Musica]
e di cinque di seguito ecco cosa vuoi
che trattati 2
adesso sei così
perché
mi sa che vediamo se c'è ancora prima di
arrivare a farli integrare abbiamo vinto
o perso un momento
[Musica]
abbiamo vinto io e societari divenne la
gameplay primo errore grande puffo mi
sono sei credibile così
questo è il video che avete visto spero
vi sia piaciuto mi sono in un video solo
mi sono tinti capelli pinto la maglietta
che non l'avrò buttata con la dino
micolano anche più tinto anche la
dignità quindi ragazzi spero che questo
video vi sia piaciuto concludo
quell'episodio cosa egli ha vissuto il
momento è un mi piace anche ai vari
social che come i video totale
descrizione si scateni ci mettiamo così
un video per ragazzi